let's think about this we've got we've
got one geometric idea here I want to
give you another geometric idea
right what they have done is you can
think about like zip one put said to and
when I can think about this piece I take
said one and I've adjusted somehow with
this operation chord plus zi2 right so
I've gone from dead woman and somehow
I've arrived up here okay now one
geometric transformation corresponds to
taking a point and then really
horizontally a bit and then moving it
vertically a bit what's that chord
starts with T it's cold when you slide
something around
it's called trans translation I
translate when you take a shape and you
just slide it on
so in other words like addition here
addition is equal to translation
geometrically that's what you're really
doing when you're adding these complex
numbers you are tread leading things
around according to the size of the real
imaginary parts all right now that was
addition now you would think of
subtraction as like subtraction is just
a form of addition right but before I
can do that like to say for instance
said one takeaway said to this really is
addition what two numbers in my attic
oh very good concept one the number I'm
adding
says add one to result in - is I'm
adding negative is it - okay
now even though like this is so trivial
in real numbers that you're not even
willing to think about it in complex
numbers as you seem like with the square
roots that demonstrated yesterday you've
got to be very careful with things and
not just assume things right so this is
my coordination right slapping a minus
sign on something what does negation me
geometrically right I know what addition
means what does negation slapping a
minus sign on it do well if I want
negative Zed - right I know what that
means in arithmetic terms right if this
is said - and negative said - I just
treat it like a binomial I take the real
imaginary parts and I multiply this by
minus one you happy with that so this
will be minus one minus 5i now where is
this on my our get diagram where do I
plot it on the complex plane a cake sir
if centuries are bad then it's negatives
it to is a minus one I've gone that way
and - one - two - three - four - five I
right so I'm down yeah this is negative
Z - so you can see if I connect again my
green lines my intervals right is just
going on my um my scale is not the
greatest so it's not immediately
apparent maybe but negatives are -
negation how is it related to the
regulars in - it's been now there's two
ways to think about this okay I will
write down both of them um negation it
looks like a reflection doesn't it and
that fits into our schema feet of my
translation was one of the
transformations we knew about reflection
is another one it sure enough it does
look reflected across we're gonna write
reflection I'm just gonna write it in
brackets as you'll discover shortly a
reflection is actually not the most
helpful way to think about it and you
guys know that the different
transformations can be expressed in
terms of each other what other
transformation could I apply to Z -
together - negative Z - yeah
very good okay so another way on color
another way I could get from Z to two
negatives that too is I go around the
origin and I can rotate now say it with
me how far by rotating I'm ready pirate
PI radians around I'm gonna quit
hi there okay sir
negation recommendation even though it
does look like reflections a better way
of understanding it is its rotation
about the origin or by pi radians okay
you might hit men that says so much more
awkward than this okay I just so pop it
in the back of your mind that even
though in this particular instance those
are equivalent this is my superior all
right now that I don't negate is I'm
ready to do subtraction I can do
subtraction because now I know where
negative Z 2 is so I can add Z 1 and
they use their - where is it going to go
well let's just do the arithmetic shall
we let's let's do the arithmetic any
more space the arithmetics the easy part
zib one takeaway sent to okay here we go
so you got three take away one which is
and then you got I take away five on
which is minus y right where is this on
our complex plane looks to me like it's
one two one two three four
is that right that's really bad scale
but no sorry guys
there is one takeaway that okay now I
think you just behave and be able to say
on my diagram what's going on here what
is subtraction mean well remember
subtraction is still a form of addition
as I've tried to make the heel right but
can you see I'm kind of going in a
different direction
kind of but nerds like ah I think a
better way to think about it is again
firstly in terms of translation and the
kind of translation that I choose is
going to give me a parallelogram
according to the parallelogram for right
you can draw it in right can you see it
okay so you see I still have a
parallelogram right because if
subtraction is still a fulcrum addition
right so it still gives you this
parallelogram but it gives you a power
that I gram in another direction okay
just really quickly can you imagine
where would you expect this was in one
take ways it to where would you expect
the Zed to take away is it once a bit
it's gonna be in the top left isn't it
right because if you think about where
Zed one is then negative Z 1 will be
yeah right and so when you take [ __ ]
at one and apply it as a translation -
zip - you've gone this way so therefore
just to make our diagram even poor full
right you're gonna get I guess would be
something like this that would be the
parallelogram you get you keep on
getting parallelograms just depending on
what combination you got by the way
there's a parallelogram missing what is
it - everyone - there - right in fact
it's the negative parallelogram of this
guy I obviously you just go in the
opposite direction because the negation
of this dotted line will be rotation pi
radians